arrivé à 8h30 les avocats de muriel
bolle ne le savent pas encore mais cette
audience va être un véritable marathon
tout comme les défenseurs des époux
jacob ils viennent plaider la nullité
des mises en examen de leurs clients
après trois heures d'audience à la
faveur d'une pause
l'avocat de jacqueline jacob exposé ses
arguments il faut bien comprendre que la
loi fait obligation à tout magistrat qui
met en examen une personne de l'informer
de ses droits et nous ce que nous
mettons en avant c'est que madame jacobs
au moment de sa mise en examen n'a pas
été régulièrement informé de ses droits
après plus de 4h30 l'audience s'achève
enfin l'avocat de marcel jacob a tenté
lui aussi de mettre en avant des
manquements de la procédure
ça a été assez interactif assez
intéressant long tout tout tout le
dossier a été détricoté repris en ce qui
concerne les éléments procéduraux il
convient maintenant d'attendre sagement
la décision la chambre de l'instruction
rendra sa décision sur ces demandes le
16 mai outre une requête de nullité de
la mise en examen de leur cliente
les avocats de muriel bolle on demandait
la levée de son contrôle judiciaire il
s'agit de sortir muriel de la situation
dans lesquelles elle est à l'heure
actuelle elle est injustement accusé
on utilise on a utilisé tous les moyens
contre elle y compris des moyens de
contrainte qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
pas justifiables dans une procédure
comme celle là nous espérons que
aujourd'hui est une étape importante
vers la sortie de cette situation muriel
bolle sera fixé sur son contrôle
judiciaire le 25 avril dans ses
réquisitions le procureur général a
demandé le rejet intégrale de ses
demandes
la procédure n'étant pour lui pas
juridiquement critiquable